[Music]
breath of the wild took a new approach
to items whereas in previous games you
would slowly build up an arsenal of
unique tools through the course of the
game in breath of the wild there wasn't
even a separate inventory for this
everything you found in regards to items
was classified on their either weaponry
bows or shields no distinction was made
between tools for offens either and are
all pooled together under the collective
name of weapons boomerangs rod swords
spears even torches & korek leaves not
only that but with the exception of the
Master Sword none of these tools were
unique in a Link to the Past for
instance there would be only one fire
rod only one magic cape one Lantern but
in breath the wild you can have
duplicates of the same items in your
stash and all have limited use and are
disposable hence these no longer
functioned as progression items and
rather as generic tools the actual
progression items were tied to the
chicest laid in the form of the many
different rooms most of which were
obtained immediately in the tutorial
section that is the great plateau the
only exceptions being the camera
function as well as upgrades to already
existing ones like stasis plus and
remote bombs plus none of which are even
mandatory to beat the game
now of course beating the game has
gotten a whole different meaning in
rough dewild compared to previous titles
since you could go straight again and
after the great plateau if you so desire
without cheating that is but let's just
say that even conquering all of the
divine beasts and then beating ganon
doesn't require anything else than the
original five runes and the most basic
weapons you can find anywhere in the
overworld the only reason to visit pura
at all is if you want to retrieve all
lost memories which is also optional the
other items and abilities link acquires
like the paraglider and different
champion abilities simply become part of
his character they don't require to be
equipped and in the case of the
paraglider cannot even be removed this
new system of approaching items will
most likely largely be preserved in
brief the while - with this in mind and
if we are to assume that a more
traditional approach to dungeons will
return as is being speculated and even
rumored how will the sequel handle
progression items as of right now it is
still unclear if the sheikah slay will
be a returning item in Pravda while -
neither do we
if its function will be the same or if
it will be either diminished or expanded
upon there's speculation about the
possibility of Zelda being playable
alongside link not you might be the one
to operate it but that is a topic for a
different video what we want to talk
about here is the possibilities for
progression items tools that are unique
mandatory for progression and functions
similarly to the tools found in previous
games like the hookshot hammer beetle
and more as mentioned before probe the
wise approach to progression items
differs greatly from past games so the
most likely scenario will be that the
Zelda team will present a mix between
the old and the new progression items no
longer being a standalone object that
link obtains a rod to become part of his
character which can be swapped between
using the deep the same way we switch
between the different rules of the
sheikah slate the big different this
time around being that will not be
granted all the necessary tools right at
the start rather expand their abilities
step by step as you progress through the
game and conquer its multiple dungeon
challenges this will allow for a more
traditional approach to dungeon design
with a structure unlocks bit by bit and
finally opens up completely once we
obtain the new ability found inside
dungeon notice how we call this an
ability rather than an item we believe
that this is the new way to go for off
the wild to reverting back to the
traditional Zelda items completely would
feel like a step back in the evolution
of the series thus you'll be more
fitting to go in a new direction while
at the same time borrowing from
traditional ideas the most of this
waders can be achieved full of course
buildings afflicted hands while looking
around at some of my comments one of
them posted by Zack weygers caught my
attention he makes the point that it
would be best if items like the hookshot
and claw shot are no longer treated as
physical items but rather tied to Ling's
arm and makes a strong comparison to
Darksiders - now I have never played any
of the installments from the dark side
as franchise but being the curious man
that I am I look further into it and
followed some Let's Plays of the game
and well I think he's right on the money
here as far as comparisons go I think
this might be as close as we can get in
the game the main protagonist fittingly
named death will obtain different types
of abilities that will become part of
his character the closest to home would
be the ability called the death grip
which is almost a one-on-one copy of the
grappling hook for
winwaker or the whip from skyward sword
where you can target specific objects to
cross gaps or pull smaller objects
toward you it can even be used to expand
the distance you can traverse by running
alongside walls quick note I'm totally
picking up this game before the release
of breath the wall to this game looks
freakin amazing it is said that the
developers working on the sequel are
currently being inspired by Red Dead
Redemption 2 and another unspecified
game I wouldn't even be surprised if
this turns out to be one of the
Darksiders games since Darksiders 3 came
out at the end of 2018 half a year
before the breath Mawile 2 trailer now I
know I've made this connection many
times before but it's pretty much the
only thing we have to go on as of right
now some of the concept art presented by
the zelda team seems to point into a
similar direction instead of carrying an
actual physical hammer links hand would
instead transform into a hammer shape
and wields it as if it was an actual
physical item if this is indeed
implemented most if not all progression
abilities besides the paraglider would
probably be handled in the same way
similar to how the t1000 transforms his
hands into all kinds of different
weapons and tools the next question
would be how exactly would link obtain
these new abilities
I mean it's unlikely they would be
simply lying in a chest somewhere right
the sheikah slate has a more
technological feel to it a device that
can channel different properties to
manipulate the physical world around it
like time magnetism water molecules
create blasts of energy or capture light
to create photographs the green hand
which is speculated to be tied to the
zone I seems to have a more spiritual
element to it the biggest giveaway for
this is the color of said energy green
instead of blue green of course
correlating to the luminous stones found
across Hyrule were just said to possess
the spirits of the dead as well as the
green flames and glows seen around the
deceased champions and King roam and
this does seem to make sense when
looking at the full picture the hand
that keeps the seal on Ganondorf seems
to transfer the loss of its spirit
energy the link to give him the means to
stand a chance against whatever
Ganondorf has in store for us there's a
theory that suggests that the hand was
once a full person but over the many
millennia slowly faded from existence
sacrificing its energy slowly to keep
the seal intact living only this part of
his or her body behind
now this theory would justify what link
doesn't immediately inherit all the
great powers is being once possessed and
grows into strong magic wielding warlock
which would of course be Opie to have
right at the start of the game instead
only a sliver of its full power is left
causing linked travel the land and
overcome challenges to expand this power
gradually to some of you this might
sound far-fetched but this is actually
not that different from the champion
abilities who were able to obtain in
breath the wilds these two were tied to
the spirit energy of these characters
granting us access to the unique
abilities they possess in life so with
that in mind as stated before link could
traverse the world find hidden dungeons
and challenges to add to his abilities
either by finding Zona artifacts or the
actual spirits of deceased sir nigh
magic wielders which all possess
different abilities when they were still
around and harness their power another
and perhaps even more interesting option
would be if link has to battle a
specific boss mini boss to essentially
steal their spiritual essence and
harness its power that grants him a new
ability alternatively this battle could
even be with a diseased own high spirit
which isn't evil but simply wants to
test link to see if his worthy of
wielding this new power similar to how
the sheikah monks tested us to prove our
worth as the true hero of Hyrule of
course this is mostly just speculation
at this point and at this stage it
doesn't really matter that much how
exactly link will obtain these abilities
through the course of the game but I
hope you can see the case we're trying
to build for this new approach to how
items and in particular progression
items could work in the sequel to breath
of the wild the old-school
items we've seen in previous games will
likely for now remain in the past but we
can see something that works the same
way as the sheikah slate did but instead
with this new spirit power where
abilities become part of Link's
character but still serve the same
function as the traditional items did
and instead of hurtling a metric ton of
heavy equipment around they are all
stored inside his spiritual arm some
people speculate that link won't be able
to use his right arm to wield his sword
and instead will have to switch to being
a lefty which could be true but I can
also see it working the other way around
in past games you couldn't wield an item
and your sword at the same time same
thing goes for the sheikah slate I think
the reason why they chose it
and to be affected is to simply achieve
the same goal where you cannot use your
hammer fists and your sword
simultaneously although that would be
badass but maybe this is just to add
some kind of limitation if his hand is
at default
aka no abilities activated link would
still be able to hold a sword in his
right and fight like he normally does
there's no need for a link to all of a
sudden become a southpaw but that's just
my take a big thanks goes to Conrad for
joining me in this endeavor you can
check out his video on the Commonwealth
realm channel which dives further into
the lore and speculation on link zone I
hand and me and even Nintendo black
crisis lend our voices to the cause you
can click the end card or find the link
in the description also if you haven't
already be sure to check out MBC's
amazing 40-plus minute video about the
mystery of the zone I that is all for
now thanks a lot for watching and if you
will subscribe to the channel and turn
on those notifications if you don't want
to miss my future uploads as promised at
the end of this week we will cover
another lore video I hope to see you
there and this is dawn signing off and
have a good one